ce mardi 10 juillet les yvelines ont
vécu une nuit de liesse aux quatre coins
du département des milliers de
supporters sont sortis dans la rue pour
fêter la qualification de la france pour
la finale de la coupe du monde
[Applaudissements]
quelques heures plus tôt au palais des
sports d'elancourt les gradins avaient
pris des allures de mini stade de france
avant le match contre la belgique
les 1300 supporters présents dans cette
fan zone ont vibré sur chacune des
actions du match
[Applaudissements]
à la mi-temps la belgique et la france
le tra lise 0 à 0 je suis sûr qu'ils
vont percer la défense m ce supporteur
français était entendu six minutes après
la reprise samuel umtiti marque 1 0 pour
la france
le palais des sports chavire dans le
bonheur l'atmosphère devient de plus en
plus tendue au fil des minutes et enfin
c'est la délivrance la france est en
finale de la coupe du monde pour la
troisième fois de son histoire
on a tremblé mais je pense qu'on n'y
avait qu on ait cru dès le départ et on
a vu que dès qu'on a marqué le premier
but je pense qu'on pouvait même en voir
en prenant matin deuxième pour la ramène
des scènes de joie qui se sont
poursuivies tout au long de la nuit dans
les rues d'el en cours avec un concert
de klaxons de plusieurs heures il me le
fait que les yvelinois espère vivre à
nouveau ce dimanche 15 juillet avec une
victoire lors de la finale
[Musique]